I'm your guest bailiff,
Tiffany Haddish.
And now here's your judge,
the honorable Judge Doug!
Hey, Doug.
Hey, Tiffany.
[ Laughs ]
Ah, hello.
-Hello.
Judge Doug: It's time to play
good judge, high judge.
Which one will I be?
The plaintiff lent
the defendant her car
but never got it back.
The defendant says
the car had expired tags
and was impounded.
Latasha and Lataya, I mean,
this is not a good idea
to put a high judge
in front of this case,
'cause just keeping
your names apart
is gonna be quite difficult,
but I'm gonna give it my best.
Lataya, you brought us here.
What's your complaint?
I let Latasha use my vehicle,
which was a Lexus.
And I specifically told them
that the tags was outdated
and there was tickets
on the car.
And within two weeks,
the car was gone,
because they live
by a police station,
and they parked the car
on the street.
What? That seems like a very
safe place to park a car...
No, that's not
a safe place...
...right in front
of the police station.
...to park a car
with no tags on it.
Oh.
So they impounded it?
Yes,
and the agreement was
that $2,700 that I paid
for my vehicle
would get paid back to me.
Is that Kelley Blue Book
or Lataya Blue Book?
Yeah.
Probably a real book
that's blue, though.
[ Snickers ]